empecemos con tres puntos el punto a al
punto b y el punto ce y si suponemos que
no se encuentran sobre una misma línea
es decir que no son co lineales entonces
podemos trazar segmentos que conecten
los tres puntos para formar un triángulo
espero que ya estés familiarizado con el
concepto o la idea de lo que es un
triángulo
lo que quiero probar en este vídeo es
que la suma de los ángulos de un
triángulo suman 180 grados si este es a
b y el ángulo ce si la media son a b y c
minúsculas bueno vamos a usar otras
letras digamos x y y ceta
voy a demostrar que x + ye maceta es
igual a 180 grados
déjenme borrar un poco para dejar
espacio para la demostración y lo que
voy a hacer es empezar dibujando una
línea paralela al segmento veces que
pase por el punto del triángulo esa
línea sería esta que estoy pintando de
morado vamos a llamarla la línea l y lo
que haremos a continuación es extender
el segmento bc en una línea de tal
suerte que veamos que en efecto es
paralela a l
la línea l es paralela a la línea bs y
esto lo denotamos así l es paralela a la
línea bs
la razón por la que hacemos esto es
porque ahora los segmentos a b y ace se
convierten en líneas transversales de
nuestras rectas paralelas el ibc esto es
porque intersectan a dichas rectas
paralelas si te preguntas cómo es que
podemos construir una línea paralela a
un segmento dado y que pase por un punto
fuera de él bueno esto en la geometría
es posible y sabemos que además es una
única línea paralela lo que queremos
hacer ver es ahora a los segmentos ave y
hace como transversales de las otras dos
líneas paralelas
vamos a extender dichas líneas en este
caso la ave
línea ave
y vamos a extender la línea hace
línea
y que insisto hay que verlas como líneas
transversales a nuestras líneas
paralelas el ibex y ahora pensemos en la
suma de los ángulos dentro del triángulo
digamos que la medida de este ángulo es
x sabemos que en las líneas paralelas se
satisface la propiedad de que si hay un
ángulo entre una de las paralelas y la
transversal en este caso es x hay un
ángulo correspondiente entre esa misma
transversal y la otra paralela
sabemos que el ángulo correspondiente
mide lo mismo si el primer ángulo son 30
grados en el ángulo correspondiente
serán 30 grados también si este ángulo
mide 70 grados
entonces el correspondiente de arriba
también mide 70 grados ahora sabemos que
si éste mide x el ángulo opuesto por el
vértice también va a medir x
consideremos ahora algún otro ángulo del
triángulo digamos que la medida de este
ángulo es de la medida de este ángulo es
10 entonces nos preguntamos cuánto mide
este ángulo que estamos dibujando cuánto
mide este ángulo completo bueno este
ángulo va a medir x mas x todo esto que
estamos dibujando con un arco color
verde va a medir x todo este y nos
preguntamos si este ángulo que mide x 10
tiene algún ángulo correspondiente un
ángulo correspondiente ahora al segmento
hace y bueno si en efecto tenemos que
este ángulo es el correspondiente bueno
vamos a limpiarlo para que se vea un
poco más claro este ángulo x más ya
tiene a un ángulo correspondiente de
este lado
este ángulo también mide x por lo que
acabamos de mencionar hace unos momentos
ahora si este ángulo mide x más cuánto
mide este ángulo de aquí que estamos de
notando con signo de interrogación el
ángulo x es suplementario a este ángulo
o sea que a ambos suman 180 grados así
pues x más y más vamos a ponerlo con
otro color mejor con el verde x más y
más cambiemos de color signo de
interrogación es igual a 180 grados los
ángulos suplementarios eso satisfacen si
despejamos el valor de la incógnita
tenemos haciendo las las cuentas
necesarias qué signo de interrogación
será 180
- x
menos
entonces signo de interrogación es 180
menos x menos 10 ahora bien tal y como
hemos definido los tres ángulos vamos a
sumar los vamos a sumar este ángulo x
este ángulo x vamos a sumarlo a este
otro ángulo que hemos definido como ya
que ambos son ángulos internos y ahora
sumamos el valor de signo de
interrogación en este caso es 180 menos
x menos y ahora vamos a hacer el cálculo
está x se cancela con esta otra y
también está y se cancela con esta y
dándonos un resultado exacto de 180
grados utilizando todo lo que sabemos
sobre líneas paralelas y transversales
hemos podido demostrar que cualquier
triángulo la suma de sus ángulos
internos es 180